وقبل نهاية هذا الفيديو
اخواني اخواتي اردت اخباركم بهذا المستجد
بحزب اليمين لقب في امريكا برئاسة ايغيكسوتي
لم يقبل الصفعة التي جاءته من المجلس الدستوري
لكنسي كونستي تيسيونير
عندما الغى كل البنود التي
كان يريدها الحزب اليميني
والتي بسببها ضغط على الحكومة
وعلى رئيسة الحكومة انداك اليزابيث بون
فالبارحة
الحزب بالبرلمان اقترح مره اخرى اغيب اغيب
هو انغيب فيراندوم دينسيتيف بختاجي
استفتاء وطني او مبادره وطنيه
يعني التصويت يكون فيها للشعب الفرنسي
هذا الاجراء اخواني اخواتي ان لم يسبق له ان وجد
اذن صاغية في البرلمان في السابق
فحزب اليمين يطالب باعطاء الكلمة والتصويت للشعب الفرنسي
بخصوص قانون الهجرة
وخاصة البنود التي طبعا رفضها المجلس الدستوري
فمسلسل الهجرة
الاحزاب اليمينية واليمنية المتطرفة لا تريد انهاؤه
مع ان القانون الجديد للهجرة
بدات الحكومة تطبيقه
فحزب اليمين
يصر على موضوع الغاء
وحرمان المساعدات الاجتماعية على الاجانب
ويريد بهذا الاقتراح جمع ما امكن من الامضاءات
طبعا داخل البرلمان من طرف النواب
لتقديمه
بعدها الى المجلس الدستوري
فالاعتماد اخواني اخواتي
او القرار على هذا الاقتراح من طرف المجلس الدستوري
يجب ان يتوفر على بعض الشروط
ففي حالة ان القرار
قرار مجلس الدستور
كان هو الموافقة على تطبيق هذا الاستفتاء الوطني
فيجب بعدها على حزب اليمين اقنع خمس
1,000,000 فرنسي وفرنسية لمساندة هذا الاقتراح
قبل التصويت عليه من طرف الفرنسيين
يعني هذا ان الحزب اليميني يجب عليه جمع
5,000,000 امضاء من الفرنسيين لي طبعا تقديم
هذا الاقتراح والتصويت عليه بعد ذلك من طرف الفرنسيين
فهذا الاقتراح من طرف حزب اليمين يجب قبل ذلك
ان يجمع مئة وخمسة وثمانين امضاء داخل البرلمان
لتقديمه بعد ذلك الى
المجلس الدصوري وفي حالة
ان المجلس الدستوري وافق على هذا الاقتراح
يجب على الحزب اليميني ان يجمع 5,000,000 امضاء من طرفه
الفرنسيين
وبعدها يتم
التصويت على هذا الاقتراح
وهذا الاقتراح يضم
الغاء المساعدات الاجتماعية على الاجانب
كما قلت
والغاء التغطية الصحية
لايمر على الاجانب الذين ليس لهم اوراق
وللموضوع اخواني اخواتي بقية